bonjour à tous comment vous allez
j'espère vous allez bien je veux
aujourd'hui venir vous parler de
smartphones reconditionnés vous aura pas
échappé
vous pouvez bien évidemment acheter vos
smartphones 9 e commerce chez n'importe
quel vendeur revendeurs ou qui vous
voulez et ses smartphones une fois par
semaine maison oui bien tu vois les
revendre soit directement entre
particuliers soit vous pouvez les faire
reprendre lorsque vous allez vous
changer de smartphone et dans ce cas là
ces smartphones vendront le cirque et
qu'on appelle le reconditionner ils sont
récupérés par une entreprise ils sont
vérifiées et ils sont vendus à des
tarifs beaucoup moins et c'est
extrêmement intéressant
donc aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
reconditionnement mais c'est de voir si
c'est intéressant et je vais vous parler
de reconditionner en vous présentant le
site qui s'appelle certes idylle j'ai
commandé mais quelques temps ce produit
là qui est arrivé de chez certes idylle
c'est un smartphone haut de gamme
tréogat vachement intéressant on va donc
regarder comment fonctionne le site
certes dit on va regarder si le
reconditionner intéressante à voir si
les promesses sont tenues pour répondre
à la question est ce intéressant
d'acheter hors conditionné est une
arnaque
oui ou pas du tout la première chose à
faire c'est d'aller regarder un peu ce
qui se passe sur le site pour voir de
quelle manière ça fonctionne on se
connecte donc au site certiid hill.com
alors bon j'arrive sur un site tout ce
qui est plus classique gens que j'ai des
bons plans on propose acheteurs en
conditionné dr paul l'iphone 10 8 7
ledit sert le onze pros le onze pros qui
ferment un excellent smartphone le
dissès le rose le 11 nov l'aï dit je
pouvais retrouver l'iphone et ceux de
2020 fin j'ai plein de super bons plans
et j'ai tous les produits sur le côté
que ce soit des iphone des samsung
je vais avoir différents bon plan
détaille d'ailleurs gros plan c'est quoi
ça ça m'intéresse beaucoup qu'est ce
qu'ils ont en un plan bien voyez j'ai
une fois de plus beaucoup de fans ils
ont beaucoup beaucoup de produits apple
c'est super cool à des tarifs vraiment
intéressant et une fois de plus en cette
période de l'année avec le black friday
des bons pour y en a beaucoup
j'invite donc aller faire un tour sur le
site de sortie ville pour regarder les
bons plans que j'aime bien mais
évidemment bas dans la description votre
voix des tablettes des ipad des
accessoires d apple watch autant vous
dire qu'ici vous avez de quoi faire et
un droit pour tout le monde moi par
exemple ce qui va m'intéresser c'est
d'acheter à des derniers iphone alors
pas l'iphone doute cette année parce
qu'il vient de sortir il n'est pas
encore en reconditionnés mais par contre
je serais intéressé par un iphone iphone
ondes de l'année dernière c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait sur les
process donc il sait j'ai mon iphone 11
64 gigas
ok je peux je fais venir regarder
ensuite qu'est ce que je vais avoir j'en
ai plein d'autres je vais en avoir en
blanc move en rouge en est en noir
allez on va partir là dessus on va se
regarder un smartphone en très bon état
en noir fait voir voire plus qu'est ce
que ça me raconte ça alors là c'est
intéressant parce que voyez j'ai mon
smartphones reconditionnés
j'ai plusieurs états je vais avoir bon
état à 637 90 je vais avoir très bon
état à 644 et je vais avoir comme neuf à
661 euros
j'ai moins de 30 euros entre le bon et
i'll comme des photos vous dire que moi
je vais choisir le comme neuf je peux
descendre est vrai que j'ai des rapports
de l'expérience assez intéressant tout
ce qui a été testée batterie tester
façade arrière prix jack lightning le
micro le réseau les différents boutons
beauty home le vibreur vérification de
l'état de marche du bouton silence par
appui prolongé donc à tous process de
test j'ai ensuite l'ex parti ça
n'explique qui est serti liste une
entreprise française de vente et de
reconditionnement de téléphones mobiles
nomme service achats s'approvisionne
auprès des opérateurs
donc ça vous voyez d'où viennent vos
smartphones en fait lorsque quelqu'un va
changer sur smartphone d'oppression
opérateurs elle fait reprendre et bien
ils sont récupérés par certes idylle ils
vont pouvoir ensuite vous voulez
revendre après vérification et de
certification donc ça s'est très très
bien qu'ils voulaient reprennent des
smartphones
n'ayant connu qu'un seul et unique
propriétaire ou les non pas sur vos
smartphones qui ont connu plusieurs
propriétaires ce qu'on appelle une
première main comme dans l'automobile
c'est rassurant chacun des produits
mentionnés mis à la vente sur notre site
est alors récupéré physiquement par nos
soins et suite dans nos locaux un
processus d'homologation en trois étapes
vérification test certification nos
experts sont ainsi les premiers
interviewer techniquement sur le produit
que nous reconditionnant nous même en
interne sans autre intermédiaire c'est
l'assurance nos clients d'acheter un
téléphone en toute confiance
reconditionnés en france accompagné
d'une garantie de 24 mois et d'un
service après-vente en contact continu
avec nos espaces techniques ou ça c'est
vraiment rassurant je vais ensuite que
j'ai un avis de 9,2 sur dix sur un beat
vérifier je vais donc que je suis
satisfait ou remboursé pendant 21 jours
ça c'est bien
expédition gratuite 48 heures est
certifiée et garantie 24 mois pendant 2
ans fut tranquille pour ça c'est
vraiment cool smartphone comme ça qui
revient qu'il reconditionnés calme
d'occasion qui garanti 2 ans je peux
vous dire vous êtes vraiment vraiment
tranquille ensuite vieux cliquer sur
ajouter tac
j'ai donc mon smartphone qui me coûte
non pas 6 171 90 mais 661 euros 90 parce
qu'en ce moment il ya plein de remise et
il ya plein de super pro
par ailleurs le black friday bien
évidemment un chéquier en bas dans la
description par apax zen pour dire le
protéger en plus avec une vie de poser
par les soins et une mousse pour
seulement 17 90 bon pourquoi pas ça
c'est à vous de voir
extension de garantie 12 mois pour
passer de 24 à 36 mois je ne suis pas
persuadé déjà 24 mois vous êtes vraiment
bien avec votre smartphone et si vous
avez un smartphone affaires reprises
j'avais une offre de reprise permettra
de le toucher moins cher bien évidemment
je valide mon panier je la joute et
ensuite je crée mon compte voilà c'est
un process de vente classiques bois bon
smartphone je les achetais dans les
tares comme neuf voyages et une garantie
de 24 mois autant vous dire que c'est
extrêmement rassurant
mon smartphone est donc arrivé là dedans
dans cet emballage alors attendez bon
ben je n'ai pas ouvert donc je vais
vraiment l'ouvrir avec vous comme ça
s'ouvre là comme ça pour qu'on le voit
ensemble qui est déjà ne serait ce que
sur la protection en lui-même au niveau
du colis ça ne sont pas mal donc là j'ai
mon iphone attendait jean lurçat on va
inspecter le produit micro rayures ici
mais c'est normal l'appareil photo ici
n'est absolument pas rayé regardez là il
est vraiment hypra clean sur le côté
c'est vraiment nickel
le truc que je vois là regardez là c'est
juste là là je le vois la voyez je vois
le film qu'ils ont mis de protection là
qui est juste là on le voit ça c'est
très léger ça veut dire qu'il est
protégé
moi je le trouve vraiment bon état donc
ça s'est très très bien à l'intérieur de
la boîte on cite fait voir qu'est-ce que
je vais avoir je vais retrouver mon
chargeur ils m'ont mis une coque de
protection et ensuite ici je vais avoir
mon chargeur ouvert mon tiroir de cartes
sim
j'ai de quoi bien le charger au
lightning en usb dont j'ai tous mes cap
qui sont là donc ça c'est bien je vois
ici que j'ai un smartphone qui a pris la
charge qui prend la charge enfin ça veut
dire que c'est bon je vais venir ensuite
choisir hop français je suis dans la
région france
le tactile marche très bien pas de souci
je vois je suis connecté au wifi donc le
wifi fonctionne le tactile fonctionne il
prend la charge
moi je vous ai fait gagner du temps je
vous ai passé les étapes de
configuration l'iphone est configuré le
regarder le tactile et je regarde un peu
tous les côtés le tactile fonctionne
très très très bien de tous les côtés
j'ai accès à mes menus bouton volume
marche vers le haut ça marche
mon bouton mute ils marchent montbouton
ici fonctionne il prend la charge et
saïdi fonctionnons la caméra avant
fonctionne très bien et caméra arrière
maintenant donc l'âge et ça je peux
venir
passé en ultra grand-angle je peux venir
ici zoomer en numérique ça fonctionne
bombay différents modes eau qui est le
smartphone est fonctionnel j'ai ici un
iphone 11 à un prix qui est quand même
vachement cool tour on sait que les
produits d'apple sont pas des produits
ou les tarifs chez beaucoup il reste ce
qu'on appelle toujours une très grosse
valeur résiduelle c'est pour ça qu'un
iphone de l'année dernière vous trouvez
pas à moitié prix donc là déjà le tarif
est vachement intéressant donc pour moi
il sortit dit ça fonctionne quelles sont
les indicateurs qui me permettent de
savoir que le produit de bonne qualité
parce que moi ici je les ai reçus je les
ouvrages de test et je vous le dis mais
vous avant de commander qu'est ce qui
peut permettre de savoir ça marche bien
déjà vous avez avis vérifier une maison
indépendante avec des amis qui sont
certifiés sur laquelle certiid il ne
peut absolument pas demandé d'enlever un
avis ou un autre ça il faut le savoir
c'est le premier point en plus elle va
faire une entreprise qui est française
qui est inscrite en france où les
produits sont reconditionnés en france
donc à côté qui est quand même
extrêmement rassurant là dedans
vous avez une garantie de 24 mois à deux
ans garanties sur un produit que je vais
acheter en reconditionnés c'est quand
même plutôt cool
on a donc tous les indicateurs qui sont
dans le vert pour venir acheter un
smartphone reconditionnés de bonne
qualité directement chez sartre idylle
donc si ça vous intéresse j'ai mis le
lien bien évidemment dans la description
vos achats de fin d'année soit pour vous
pour des cadeaux si vous souhaitez
changer de smartphone et trouvez votre
smartphone dans les meilleures
conditions
acheté en france auprès d'un service qui
est français ça c'est plutôt cool
surtout en cette période où il faut
aider les entreprises françaises et bien
une fois de plus vous invite à les
découvrir et à passer par leurs amis de
certiid il le fait d'acheter ses
smartphones reconditionnés ça vraiment
un sens parce que là vous avez un
smartphone qui est par exemple l'iphone
11 et bien c'est un iphone qui est
extrêmement récent qui est toujours très
très actuel qui marche vraiment bien
qu'il n'a pas et du tout obsolète dans
les deux années à venir
ils sont tous ya un côté un peu plus
écoresponsable ça sert à rien de venir
changer sur smartphone tout le temps ça
ne sert strictement à rien donc si vous
avez besoin de changer et vous voulez
acheter dans de meilleures conditions
en achetant un produit qui vraiment de
bonne qualité reconditionnés plutôt
qu'elle a acheté tout de suite un
produit neuf et bien c'est un vrai sens
il ya un côté éco responsable c'est bon
pour la planète ça donne une deuxième
vie à ces produits dont tout ça vraiment
cool on va me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire une fois de
plus je vous invite à passer par les
liens en bas dans la description des
gros bisous beaucoup d'amour et à très
vite
ciao
ne sont ni hba1c vers nina hagen team
sky